Going through this lesson, there will be some opportunities for quizzes. And
what I'd like to do is have you consider a simple application that I'm, then,
going to be asking you questions about. The application involves users and
a web browser, visiting some kind of website and
being asked to vote on certain questions. The votes are then submitted and
the system responds back after registering the vote with some count of how
other people voted on the same, same question. So the application is web-based,
users are polled on a variety of questions, their choices are recorded,
and there's a display of how others voted. And, in this particular
situation the actual users remain anonymous as far as the database is concerned.